- At 5am, at 6am, excuse me.
6am tip: basketball, New York City.
Just a bunch of dudes
at six in the morning.
Crack of dawning.
(slow, upbeat music)
What I didn't like about this interview
is I didn't know the angle.
So make sure you at least know
what the potential headline is,
or where it's going, or what have you.
Good morning.
Welcome, have a good day.
26 minutes of pure gold.
- I think they just know that
it's 20 minutes at a time
so they go buy it.
- When I get back, I'll do a
Snapchat and push towards it.
Made no sense.
Saw your snap this morning.
- [Voiceover] How do you like that?
- I think you got potential, kid.
You're in the episode.
Stefan is filming today.
DRock's editing four. Staphon's
filming five as we speak.
Hey, mem-ul-ia, how are you?
(slow, upbeat music)
My life is now filmed at all times.
- How are you?
So good to see you.
- Where if you make a four minute video
that's high emotion,
we retarget the 87,000 people
that watched all four minutes,
they're in the franchise.
If we go right hook, right behind
them with a call to action
and get back into the
funnel, they will convert.
It's good, old-fashioned marketing.
I stood up because I'm excited.
Let me throw one other thing at you
that I'm super pumped about,
that I have a funny feeling
all of you are about to love.
- [Voiceover] It's going
to look good on TV.
- It's gonna be good, right?
Now help me with the following.
This is the most important
question for my dream.
How many of those people
do you have more an e-mail,
which means you have their phone number?
Phone number, phone number.
I would call every one of your customers.
All of them.
I'm telling you right now that
if you called these people
and said 'thank you for ever
being a customer,' that's it.
And I'm not joking when I say this.
I do not mean 'thank you and
here's some offer, reactivate.'
I literally mean, 'I'm
Sally,' and this requires,
you have to, it's not so easy at scale,
so is it 12 bucks an hour
or is it 14, is it 9,
like, you're gonna have
to find this magic,
because you need bodies.
This is called scaling the unscalable,
which is something no
company ever wants to do.
I think you could find something
pretty remarkable happening.
(slow, upbeat music)
- Matt's just taking a
restroom break for a moment.
You know, it's funny, I do edit
myself in front the camera.
I would've said something very different.
Have you gotten that at all, Gar?
Have you felt like
people edited themselves?
- I've been pretty good.
- I'm talking other people.
It's funny, I caught myself
editing myself just now.
- [Gary] You're gonna end
up being a better guy.
- Or a worse guy, not the
realest form of myself.
- Maybe.
- I just sounded so vulgar,
I was gonna say that
'taking a piss,' that just sounds vulgar.
- Oh, I say 'piss' all day, don't worry.
- I'm a better guy than you.
Staphon, Gary and I's team swept.
- [Staphon] Yeah, I heard.
- You see that broom picture?
Five-zip.
And the last two were real good.
I mean, when you have Andy,
Max, Bassabrey, and Barmer
on your team.
- They should beat us.
- They should've beaten us.
I've picken switch.
Scored three, four big buckets
on whirl in a row on that.
Yeah, we cha-van-ge a weak link.
Don't put that on camera, poor world.
- No, that, actually, I
100% want that in the show.
- Oh, man, sorry, Jeff.
You didn't play great this morning.
- Hey, guys.
- Could you close the door at least?
- Yeah, you can leave now.
- [Staphon] Alright, see you later.
(upbeat, exciting music)
- How you doing?
- Good to see you, nice seeing you again.
It was funny running
into you at the lairs.
You have the nice-neers?
Great.
Are you, get me a coffee, I'm sorry.
Yeah, thanks a bunch.
So I've been recording a daily vlog
for the last four, I've
done four episodes so far,
so literally documenting my business days.
Chloe's gonna join as well.
- I need a copy of mine.
I mean, I rarely [mumbles].
- Say hello to Chloe.
- Hi, Chloe Heckman.
Nice to meet you.
- The only religion I have is attention.
On February 2006, I watched
something called WineLibraryTV,
and hundreds of thousands
of people watched it
on Viddler, not even on YouTube.
- [Voiceover] You still
in the liquor business?
- Yeah, I still own a wine
shop, it's called Wine Library.
It's in Short Hills, New Jersey.
On this episode, I get weird.
When did he put this out?
- Just today.
- What's up, Gary Vaynerchuk?
I think I got it.
This is Daymond John, the people's shark.
Now, of course, you
know that I am huge fan
of the show.
That kind of reminds me of when
Dr. Evil said 'who? His
what? Vay-job, his vay-job.'
Anyway, don't worry about that.
So, you know I have my new book out called
The Power of Broke.
DRock, do me a favor, can
you just put that link up
- DRock getting some love.
Staphon, you're dissed.
(slow, upbeat music)
What'd they talk about?
- There's another opportunity
with the media on something else.
(beep) is coming in,
it's like an Instagram/Snapchat project.
- Okay.
(slow, upbeat music)
Let's spend more time
ones-on-ones, e-mails,
you might, you know, please, like,
not because I'm trying
to hack a couple of views
on the DailyVee stuff, like,
getting to where my psychology
is on this, understand.
Because I think, you know,
my show and now this daily thing,
I'm getting scale out
of it, right, like the,
I was able to, instead
of doing it all hands-on,
get a lot of people aligned
where my Snapchat POV is,
but like, so I'm trying to
think about these things,
I don't care how you wanna do it.
You wanna get a root beer, cool.
You know, like, I don't care how,
but what has not happened
in 2015 with a lot of you,
I mean, has to happen in
2016 with a lot of you,
which is, you just have to ask
me a couple more questions.
You just need clarity from me.
I'm super avaliable.
That's like the fucking shittiest
part of this whole rant,
right, which is like, I mean it.
Like, I'm not just saying and then, like,
'fuck, I hope they
don't hit me up,' right?
So, please use me, I wanna be used.
Plus, I change my mind every day.
I'm being serious, the market, like,
I'm a marketplace operator.
Like, I just had this impassioned,
like, cool, but in like
four months, I'll be like,
okay, we're about to do,
like, you know, so like.
What's that?
You need it?
- No, I don't need it, I
just don't wanna lose it.
- Alright, DRock, see you.
What is this bullshit?
Do you know how bad this is?
- [Voiceover] Plums?
- No, plums are delicious.
Rocks are shit.
- [Voiceover] These are really good.
- Fuck you, they're terrible.
- DRock, get this fucking.
(slow, upbeat music)
- Super cool to meet that kid.
- I told AJ, I got together,
I've been mentoring Patrick for a while.
The fact that he was, you know,
that wide endeavored incubator
fergement at sixteen,
it's some cool shit, I
was like, you know what,
this is a kid that I can get close to,
so we've been spending
a lot of time together.
- Is it something that you wanna sell,
or is it something that
you wanna drop somewhere
and operate it, or be active.
- It's fresh, it's got like.
- Like a division of.
- Exactly.
- Incubate from within.
- So you guys are a natural fit
for what you guys are doing.
- So what's the story?
- 19 years old, real hustler.
- What kind of kid were you?
Like a tech-building kid?
Like a math kid?
Like, what are you?
- My first business was fake IDs.
- That's a good start.
I love when I asked him
what his first business was.
Fake IDs.
I love that game, means he was grindin'.
- Then I did websites for nonprofits.
I went to school in Delaware.
- You needed to, like, make amends?
- Testimonials, testimony.
- Just reminds me of,
like, back in the day.
It's fun having meetings like that,
and remember, like, the early days,
like having the whole world
of business in front of you.
You know, I fucking hated school,
so having that opportunity to, like,
get into the next chapter
of my life was incredible.
I really enjoyed it, smart kid.
I love, kind of, sizing
myself up to, like,
smart, young kids,
felt like I understood
what he was talking about,
and I like that whole demeanor.
Just really wish him well.
Trying to preach him patience,
because that's the biggest
thing that most people
don't have at that age.
But for me to, like, for
me to ever do anything,
I always wanna know what
somebody wants to happen, right.
Like, I'm trying to really
figure out your patience level,
your interest level, like,
all this stuff is very easy
for me that you're saying,
mainly because I already
did it once for myself,
so I understand the levers
and things of that nature.
What I'm trying to think
about, believe it or not,
is the three-to-five years
from now, the transition.
Really hoped you guys noticed,
by the way, real quick,
my question about the
five-year plan for him.
Always trying to use that as a,
I don't think five-year
plans are practical
in today's world, but try
to use that as a proxy
of trying to understand
where somebody's head's at.
I think it's super important,
at least as of this moment,
where do they see their life going.
What's the best outcome for you?
Like, literally you, like, if I was like,
I'm a crazy genie and anything you say now
will actually happen that exact way,
in a Vayner world or anywhere else,
what would happen?
Seriously, like, tell me the
next five years or three years.
Like, give me three or four bullet points.
How do I help you achieve,
at least of this moment,
especially at this young of an age,
what happens in the
macro economic climates.
A lot of this will change,
but for me to like,
for me to ever do anything,
I always wanna know what
somebody wants to happen.
So, in the comments on
YouTube and Facebook,
I would love to know what
your five-year plan is,
even though it's not practical.
I would love the insight
onto where your head's at.
That's it.
You know, yesterday,
obviously, interesting day.
Today was really focused,
had a lot of shit I wanted
to get accomplished,
which was nice, did that,
went to the Knicks game,
that was a lot of fun.
Big win, excited about that,
and now heading to my next meeting.
I'll send DRock a quick
little snap of that,
so, you know, grinding, man, 24/7.
Hustle life.
I've enjoyed the feedback from everybody
about seeing the real hustle.
I'm stunned how many didn't believe,
but, anyway, talk to you.
("The Traveler" by NAEM)